There's something absolutely hilarious going
on that is taking over the life of Republican
Senate majority leader Mitch McConnell, and
it's the nickname Moscow Mitch, the nickname
Moscow. Mitch is sticking to McConnell like
bad ideas. Stick to Republicans and he just
cannot get away from it. Now, the reason he's
being called Moscow match, there are actually
numerous reasons. One is that he keeps blocking
every single election security that's meant
to prevent foreign interference in our elections,
including from countries like Russia, which
we know interfered in 2016 and over the weekend,
a crowd chanting Moscow, Mitch, the Mitch
McConnell so loudly that it drowned him out
for a significant portion of the audience.
This was at some kind of picnic event in Fancy
Farm Kentucky and it was hilarious. The mics
are close to McConnell here, so you'll hear
McConnell, but you'll start to hear the chanting
coming from the back.
We've hit and sustain the lowest unemployment
rate in Kentucky's recorded history. And there
are far more open jobs than people looking
for work nationwide. Of the top four of the
top four congressional leaders, I'm the only
one, not from New York or California. I'm
the guy that sticks up for Middle America
and Birkin Chucky, I'd say the Supreme Court.
I just love it. A McConnell increasingly struggling
to be heard over the Moscow, Mitch chanting.
Uh, the hill TV host and political consultant.
Crystal Ball was at this event and posted
video to her social media that she token.
She's a little bit further back in the crowd.
You can't even hear McConnell back there because
of the Moscow Mitch chance.
[inaudible]. It
is absolutely delightful that this is catching
on and it should catch on. Given what he's
done. He's blocked the duty to report act,
which would require a presidential campaigns
to report to the FBI offers of assistance
from foreign countries. Something Donald Trump
recently said. Yeah, I don't know. I would
take the help in 2020 from China or Russia.
I don't know if I'd actually report it to
the FBI. There was a bill that would require
that reporting. McConnell blocked it. McConnell
blocked the securing America's Federal Elections
Act, which has been passed by the house. It
would direct $600 million in election assistance
assistance to states and require paper backup
ballots. There was a bipartisan bill which
would have required companies like Facebook
and Google to disclose who is buying political
ads in order to suss out foreign influence.
McConnell blocked that. There was a bipartisan
bill to ease cooperation between state election
officials and federal intel agencies.
McConnell blocked it. McConnell blocked a
bipartisan bill imposing sanctions on entities
that attack a u s election. McConnell blocked
a bipartisan bill, a bill with new sanctions
on Russia for its cyber crimes. And it's been
one after, after another. And here is the
sort of segue that I think is the most important
one for us here. Moscow. Mitch has an opponent
in 2020 Amy McGrath, Moscow Mitch could be
removed in 2020 from his Senate seat. Moscow,
Mitch isn't that popular in Kentucky? His
opponent is someone you can support and is
someone that you can donate to. It's Amy McGrath.
Look her up. I've talked about her before.
There is an opportunity here to remove, I
mean, in addition to Ted Cruz, one of the
most disgusting members of the U S Senate.
But unlike Ted Cruz, McConnell has been much
more effective and efficient at actually getting
really horrible things done for the Republican
Party. Uh, hey, if you want to see a hilarious
hate mail that I got a, follow me on Instagram
at David. Dot. Pacman. I posted it there this
morning. And while you're there, follow the
David Pakman show as well.
Instagram at David Pakman show. Let's take
a quick break, so much more to talk about
right after this